Congratulations to solving the first challenge. That's really, really great. Now
it's going to get a little bit more difficult. This time
we're going to introduce noise in your measurements, which means you
can't really see the X Y coordinates exactly anymore. You see
them approximately. Now this is a challenging problem, and the reason
is, everything in class that we've talked about so far was
linear, but here the motion model is non linear. So when
you apply a thing like a common filter or a particle
filter, you will be in for a surprise. So give it a try. It
might take longer than you think, but I hope you can solve this challenge.